well the pandemic may have slowed
commercial air travel but a lot more
people apparently are getting on board
now
with traveling on a private jet
companies are seeing a rising demand
from people who are worried about
exposure
or cramped terminals in the age of cobit
but let's be real a private jet is
pretty costly kirsten joyce now joining
us with more a reasonable
alternative denise with 81 percent of
north american travelers planning to fly
domestically in the next six months
and folks reunited with family and loved
ones many for the first time this year
travelers are seeking less crowded and
safer travel alternatives such as jsx
the burbank las vegas market to this day
is our strongest market alex wilcox is
the ceo of jsx
airlines stands for joyful simple
experience a semi-private jet offered to
the public
minus the expensive price tag you can
fly for 89
one way our biggest airplanes have 30
seats on them they're built for 50 seats
but we took some
some seats out to make some more room
it's all about convenience and time
saved other you know airport terminals
will tell you show up at least two hours
before your flight
we just we say please don't until 20
minutes before your flight
you do you're wasting a lot of time the
airline started five years ago with a
concord to burbank route followed by its
most popular
one burbank to las vegas as many as 14
flights a day in each direction here we
are
more or less on the hour doubling its
number of flights every year until of
course the pandemic hit
but now that more people are starting to
feel comfortable to travel again
jsx's business since april has steadily
picked up
and continues to do so in travel hubs
like las vegas reno and arizona
even adding a route from vegas to dallas
due to strong demand
i can tell you that 65 of the business
is las vegas too
so it's a huge part of our comeback
story the airline has ramped up cleaning
and rolled out new sterilization and
contactless protocols
we were social distancing before it was
even cool kirsten uh there was lots of
space in the lounge you know on a per
customer basis we didn't have the
same old security line uh you're not
taking your shoes off you know for
anybody no one's going to go through
toilet kits so
the likelihood of transmitting you know
anything uh even the common cold is
actually lower
uh the fewer people you're exposed to i
asked alex
how he's able to make the flight so
affordable he says it's part of their
efficiency model they don't have
constraints at terminals don't have to
wait for hundreds of people to board
if it costs five thousand a flight for
an hour and you divide that by 30 people
that's how you can get the reasonable
amount to charge